>> RUSSIA IS UNLEASHING A NEW
WE WAVE OF MISSILE AND DRONE
STRIKES ON UKRAINE, CAUSING
EMERGENCY POWER OUTAGES FOR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
UKRAINE SAYS IT SHOT DOWN MOST
OF THE MISSILES.
61 OF THE 71 LAUNCH THAT
UKRAINE ON FRIDAY.
THE STRIKES HIT THE
SOUTHEASTERN CITY OF
ZAPORIZHZHIA.
THESE IMAGES SHOW SOME OF THE
DAMAGE AS WELL AS THE KHARKIV
REGION, WHERE UKRAINE SAYS IT
SHOT DOWN SEVERAL IRANIAN MADE
DRONES OVERNIGHT.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT VLADIMIR
ZELENSKYY'S BACK IN KYIV AFTER
MEETING A READER READERS IN
BRUSSELS ON THURSDAY.
HE MADE A PLEA FOR WESTERN
FIGHTER JETS.
WHICH IS OFFICIALLY ASKED THE
NETHERLANDS FOR ETHNIC --
CNN INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
DAVID MCKENZIE JOINS US LIVE
FROM THE CAPITAL OF KYIV.
I UNDERSTAND THESE TALKS
REPORTEDLY CAME IN WAVES WITH
THE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS.
HOW MUCH DAMAGE WAS CAUSED
OVERNIGHT?
>> NOT AS MUCH DAMAGE COULD
HAVE OCCURRED THERE WAS A WAVE
OF ATTACKS, AT LEAST SOME PART
ON THE IRANIAN DRONES PERHAPS
TO TRY TO BRING IN THE
FIREPOWER, WHICH WAS THE
MISSILE SYSTEM AND ROCKET
ATTACKS.
ACCORDING TO THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY, THERE WERE LAND, C,
AND AIR BASE MISSILES WHICH TRY
TO STRIKE ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
THE, EAST SOUTH, AND WEST OF
THE COUNTRY.
IT APPEARS MOSTLY FOR THE
TARGET CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR POWER GENERATION.
AS YOU SAID, SOME 60 ODD OF THE
70 MISSILES IN UKRAINE WHO WERE
SHOT AT THE TERRITORY, AND WERE
TAKEN DOWN.
THAT'S A VERY HIGH SUCCESS RATE,
FOR THE AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM.
STILL, THEY HAVE HAD TO DO
PLANNED OUTAGES IN THIS COUNTRY,
AS WELL AS UNPLANNED OUTAGES IN
PARTS OF THE EAST, AT LEAST.
IT APPEARS TO BE THE CONTINUING
EFFORTS BY THE RUSSIANS TO
STRIKE AT THE CIVILIAN TARGETS
IN PART TO CRIPPLE THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
BUT ALSO TO STRIKE UP THE
MORALE OF THE UKRAINIANS.
EVEN TODAY PEOPLE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WILL HIT THE SUBWAY
SYSTEM, DOING THEIR WORK AND
CONTINUING ON AS NORMAL.
DESPITE THE AIR SIRENS GOING ON
REPEATEDLY THROUGH THE DAY SO
FAR.
THIS WILL BE SEEN AS A
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS, I THINK.
IN TERMS OF THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
BUT THIS COMES AS THERE IS
CERTAINLY AN INCREASE IN
ACTIVITY IN THE EAST OF THE
COUNTRY BY THE RUSSIANS, TRYING
TO POTENTIALLY SOFTEN UP THOSE
DEFENSES.
AND ALL OF, TALKS STILL, BY
UKRAINIANS ABOUT A POSSIBLE
SPRING OFFENSIVE BY RUSSIAN
FORCES.
CHRISTINA.
>> DAVID, JUST FOLLOWING THE
TRIP TO EUROPE THIS WITH A
DIRECT REQUEST TO THE
NETHERLANDS FOR THE F-16
FIGHTER JETS.
AS I UNDERSTAND, THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY STRATEGIC IN THE
NETHERLANDS ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF PHASING OUT THOSE WARPLANES.
DOES THAT NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
THEY WILL SUPPLY THEM?
>> NOT IN THE SHORT TERM.
THERE IS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
HAPPENING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
YOU'VE SEEN UKRAINIANS PUSH
PUBLICLY.
NOT JUST IN THAT OFFICIAL
REQUEST BUT MULTIPLE TIMES IN
RECENT WEEKS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE SWING OF
ZELENSKYY THROUGH THE UK AND
EUROPE, PUSHING HARD FOR
FIGHTER JETS AND OTHER
SOPHISTICATED WEAPONS.
AS HE HAS BEEN THROUGHOUT THIS
NEARLY EAR CONFLICT, TRYING TO
GET BETTER WEAPONS SYSTEM INTO
THE COUNTRY.
THEY KNOW THE LANDS FOR THEIR
PART RECEIVE THAT.
REQUEST THEY, ARE YOU ARE,
RIGHT DECOMMISSIONING MORE THAN
20 F-16 FIGHTER JETS FROM THE
AIR FORCE.
THEY SAY TO --
THEIR IN THE NOVEL IS THAT THEY
TOOK ALL THESE REQUESTS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
THEY SAY THAT IT IS A COMPLEX
SYSTEM THAT MEANS A GREAT DEAL
OF SUPPORT, MAINTENANCE AND
TRAINING.
BUT THIS IS WHAT ALLIES HAVE
SAID OF MANY SYSTEMS THAT HAVE
ENDED UP IN UKRAINIAN HANDS.
AT THE, STAGE LEAVING OPEN FOR
POSSIBLE SUPPLY.
WHEN IT WOULD NOT BE SOMETHING
YOU CAN JUST SET OVER IN THE
SHORT TERM.
CHRISTINA.
>> FOOD WE CAN SEE THERE, LIVE
FOR US IN KYIV.
DAVID, THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH OUR NEXT GUEST HAS BEEN
TWEETING ABOUT HIS CLOSE CALL
WITH MISSILES.
TIMOTHY --
A FORMER UKRAINIAN MINISTER OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INTO TRADE,
SAID THIS.
MULTIPLE RUSSIAN MISSILE
ATTACKS ACROSS UKRAINE, ONE
MISSILE JUST FLEW OVER ME.
NOT A FUN EXPERIENCE.
TEN MISSILES ARE SHOT DOWN OVER
KYIV.
THERE ARE TWO OVER ODESSA.
THERE ARE SOME, HITS AT LEAST
IN KYIV AND THE LVIV REGION, SO
FAR NO CASUALTIES.
COHEN MISSILE TRAVEL THROUGH
MOLDOVA, AND TIMOTHY --
JOINS US, NOW LIVE, FROM LVIV.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WE HEARD THAT THE GOVERNMENT
ARE ISSUING WARNINGS FOR THIS
MISSILE ATTACK, HAPPENED.
SADLY, AS YOU'RE HEARING FROM
DAVID MCKENZIE THERE IN KYIV,
THAT DID NOT ACTUALLY STOP THE
WIDESPREAD DESTRUCTION TO YOUR
ENERGY FACILITIES IN SIX
DIFFERENT REGIONS.
WHAT IS A SCALE OF THE DAMAGE
TO YOUR POWER GRIDS?
>> SEVERAL POWER STATIONS WERE
HIT, AT LEAST FOUR.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER REGIONS
HAVE COME UNDER PRESSURE.
BUT ALSO, SOME OF THE MISSILES
LANDED IN THE AREA WHERE THERE
WAS NOTHING JUST FIELDS.
ONE LANDED BY A BUS STOP.
FORTUNATELY, NO ONE WAS KILLED.
AND 61 OUT OF 71 HAS BEEN SHUT
DOWN.
WHICH IS A REMARKABLE SUCCESS,
I'D SAY.
>> AND OF COURSE, ALL OF THIS
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR MORE
WEAPONRY AND MORE ARMS AND MORE
SUPPORTS FROM YOUR ALLIES.
WE, SAW OF, COURSE PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY TRYING TO RALLY
LEADERS IN EUROPE FOR THE PAST
48 HOURS FOR EXACTLY THAT.
HOW SUCCESSFUL AS HE THEN IN
THAT MISSION?
>> THE LANDSCAPE MANAGES TO DO
THINGS THAT NOBODY THINKS COULD
BE POSSIBLE.
IN THAT SENSE, I AM PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL GET TO
THE AIR FORCE.
BUT IT IS ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT
DELAYED, IT IS ALWAYS THE
NUMBERS ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE
ONES THAT WE NEED.
AND SO, IN THE AND WE COVER
FORT WITH PEOPLES LIVES.
AND I THINK IT IS JUST
DISMAYING.
>> YOU HEARD US TALKING JUST
THEN ABOUT THE F-16 FIGHTER
JETS FROM THE OTHER LINES.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT YOU
WILL RECEIVE MORE PLANES?
AND WITHIN THE TIMEFRAME NEEDED,
MUCH HAS BEEN SEEN WITH THE
DELIVERY OF TAKES.
DO YOU THINK YOU COULD GET THEM
AND GET THEM WITHIN THE
TIMEFRAME NEEDED?
>> I THINK WE WILL GET THEM.
I AM NOT SO SURE ABOUT THE
TIMEFRAME.
BECAUSE INDEED, THESE SYSTEMS
ARE MORE COMPLEX AND IT DEPENDS
ON HOW MUCH OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN UKRAINE IS
AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEM.
I AM PRETTY CONFIDENT THAT THE
TRAINING CAN BE DONE RELATIVELY
QUICKLY.
AND SO IT IS JUST NOT THE
PLANES ALONE WITH A LOT OF THE
SYSTEMS AROUND THEM, THAT WE
NEED TO DO IT RIGHT.
>> TIMOTHY, I JUST WANT TO SHOW
OUR VIEWERS A TWEET THAT YOU
HAD TO JUST RECENTLY ABOUT YOUR
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT.
YOU SAID THAT UKRAINE'S DEFENSE
MINISTER PROMISES TO CONTINUE
REFORM, TO REFORM THE MINISTRY,
DESPITE THE WAR.
IN RESPONSE TO THE RECENT
PROCUREMENTS SCANDAL.
IN MY VIEW, THIS IS A SIGN OF
HEALTH AND --
THE PATINA OF CORRUPTION.
REZNIKOV IS THE BEST DEFENSE
MINISTER IN THE HISTORY OF
UKRAINE.
SO, HAVING SAID THAT, TIMOTHY,
ARE YOU SAYING THAT REZNIKOV
WILL BE STAYING IN HIS POST?
>> AT THIS MOMENT, IT APPEARS
HE WILL.
I AM ACTUALLY HOPING THAT HE
SHOULD.
BECAUSE HE IS DOING A GREAT JOB
ON ALL OF THESE FRONTS.
IT IS TRUE THAT THIS AREA OF
PROCUREMENT HAS BEEN
OVERLOOKED.
AND HE HAS POLITICAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE ALSO TO BE
REALISTIC, BECAUSE HIS PRIMARY
FOCUS IS ON DELIVERING ARMS.
I AM NOT DEFENDING HIM.
AND IN FACT, I THINK THIS IS A
STRUCTURAL ISSUE.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEFENSE
PROCUREMENT, NON-ARM
PROCUREMENTS LIKE FOOD SUPPLIES
AND SOME OF THE OTHER EQUIPMENT
SUPPLIES, THE NON MILITARY, HAS
BEEN AN REFORMED.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
INFORMANTS AND TRAITORS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE VESTED
INTERESTS AND DEEP STATES.
I KNOW SOME OF THEM PERSONALLY
AND THEY GO BACK TO THE 19 90S
AND 2000S.
SOME OF THEM WORK WITH RUSSIA.
SOME OF THEM ARE JUST TRYING TO
ENRICH THEMSELVES.
SO IN THAT SENSE WE ARE
FIGHTING TO BATTLES.
ONE ON THE FRONT LINES, AND NOW
THEY'RE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO SABOTAGE OUR DEFENSE
EFFORTS.
>> HOW CONCERNING, IS IT THEN,
TO HAVE THIS INTERNAL DIVISION
GOING ON?
THIS CORRUPTION?
THESE PEOPLE TRYING TO SABOTAGE
YOUR OPERATION, SO CLOSELY TO
WHAT WE EXPECTED TO BE THE
SPRING OFFENSIVE?
>> I WILL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE,
A PERSONAL EXAMPLE.
I WAS A MINISTER, AND I FIRED A
PERSON WHO I BELIEVE WAS
CORRUPT.
I COULD NOT PROVE, IT SO THEY
SUED ME IN THE OPEN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION AGAINST.
ME, LATER THEY WANT THEIR JOBS
BACK.
AND DURING THE WAR, THEY
ACTUALLY STOLE SOME MONEY, FOR
PROCUREMENT IN A SIMILAR WAY.
AND NOW THEY ARE WANTED ON THE
FBI, ON THE YEAR --
UP SOME WANTED AND SOME ARE
ARRESTED AND WILL SERVE THE
TERMS.
SO THERE ARE PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
AND WE HAVE TO GET RID OF THEM,
TOO.
SO IT IS CONCERNING, BUT IT IS
GREAT THAT WE ARE DOING.
IT IS JUST CHALLENGING TO DO
IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
TIMOTHY MYLOVANOV, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
I AM SURE WE WILL TALK AGAIN IN
THE DAYS TO COME.
THANK YOU.